[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
une équipe qui est avec moi autour de
moi mais et est engagée pour la ville de
trappes et les habitants de frappe avec
une passion est évidente et nomma pour
un parcours de carrière politique
et puis un apport de personnalités dont
les compétences sont des compétences
associées hâtez-vous les compétences
professionnelles qui se sont ajoutés
j'allais dire aux anciens entre
guillemets l'humain et et l'urbain parce
que les deux les deux vont ensemble
donc ce qui concerne l'humain la
solidarité et la culture
l'autre aspect c'est celle urbain il
nous reste deux
j'allais dire trois problèmes essentiels
car le problème essentiel c'est conduire
et la réalisation du plateau urbain dont
les travaux sont commencés maintenant et
ça va durer trois ans deuxième axe c'est
l'éco quartier camp de fer à la halle
freyssinet à l'entrée de troupes là-bas
où c'est un un dépôt de tout et
n'importe quoi
et puis il y a le troisième pôle une
allure dans ce site ou quartier ya donné
donné un temps de vacances de qualité
mais aussi de plaisir de partage depuis
les petits ponts zafar et les petits
enfants jusqu'au jusqu'au au seigneur ce
projet est prêt il faut appuyer
maintenant comme on dit c'est facile sur
le bouton on avron marché est
équivalente
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]